thank you very much for joining our
course
uh please tell us a bit more about
yourself and your role as ceo
and founder of flagship pioneering sure
well
uh thanks for inviting me um so i
uh i've been involved in innovation
and entrepreneurship in the life
sciences for about 31 years
i did a phd in what was then a new field
biochemical engineering
and since then have found different ways
of deriving value from
from making breakthroughs in that area
and
initially i i followed the kind of
traditional route of developing
technologies raising capital and
developing startup companies
venture-backed startup companies and
then more recently what flagship
pioneering really specializes in
is in a different way of of thinking
about both innovation
and entrepreneurship uh and we're
looking to systematize the process and
make it something that an institution
can do
instead of a group of individuals great
so tell me first how you got into how
you got the bug
of of taking technologies and bringing
them to market what was the spark
that got you on this i you know
different people are are inspired by
different things in my case it was
actually quite memorable
um i had no intention or no idea in 1985
graduate students uh let alone you know
kind of not from this country
didn't exactly think that they were
going to go off and start a company
that's a pretty recent phenomenon in the
last 15 years or so
but back but so i was a graduate student
working in in a pretty esoteric kind of
project
and i happened to find myself uh at an
nsf conference that mit had sent me to
i have to remember in the 1980s the us
was worried that it was going to lose
its competitiveness against japan
and there were all these kind of
meetings about how are we going to
compete with japan et cetera
and they must have needed somebody who
knew how to spell biotechnology so they
sent me down
and at this conference which was
otherwise utterly boring
i happened at lunch to sit with somebody
and i got enough
courage to to ask him what he did and
who he was and stuff
and he started telling me how he had
started a company some 35 years earlier
with another friend of his and
and they were a new breed of engineer
this was electronic engineer they came
out of the power industry
and i was listening to a story and you
know this is kind of i
had nothing to relate to except when he
said new breed of engineer i kind of
thought well that's interesting i'm a
new breed of engineer and engineers had
not done biology
ever in the past and he said you know
they didn't know what these engineers
would make but they knew they would need
to measure whatever they made
and so he and this friend of his started
this effort to make an oscilloscope
in their garage and they started selling
it to their friends
and and then that led them to make even
more products
and so it's kind of interesting i had no
idea who he was and but it was
interesting to
to relate to you know i i was a new
breed of engineer
we didn't know what biological engineers
would make but we didn't know that they
were going to need to measure things
and so you know probably out of a
deficiency of fairly linear thinking as
engineers sometimes have
i was just mapping it to me and i think
oh that's interesting and then i asked
him who he was and it was david packard
yeah from hewlett-packard and he was to
either spend the next couple of hours
telling me just one on one that's just
you know out of out of
i could have been sitting in a park
bench with the guy i mean he was
literally just very relatable
and literally i came back to mit to my
graduate you know kind of
lab and then i thought well how am i
going to figure out how to do this i
really wanted to do this
and i went to sloan school and said can
i take courses they had absolutely no
courses on
entrepreneurship at the time now
everybody has a thousand courses but it
was not something i was taught
so that's when i actually started
finding my way to eric von hippo's class
and to
several other people's classes were
teaching management of technology
innovation there was a corporate venture
capital course i took i don't know why
all to just kind of get myself
introduced to that and that's kind of
how i started
that's incredible so to david packard it
was the source of uranus it was randomly
randomly because because he was he was
relatable yeah you know it's kind of
one of the things i've learned over all
these years i've done this is that
sometimes
people make entrepreneurship some kind
of almost like a like a
you know like art or science or you know
there's almost celebrity associated with
it and i and i always resent that
because
it makes it unrelatable it makes it look
like you know when i i like playing
basketball but when i look at michael
jordan i realize i'm not going to be him
yes and and those kinds of celebrity
figures don't encourage
the sport they actually discourage the
sport i mean without wanting because you
said i'm never going to be that
well he was a guy who was clearly a
celebrity in doing that
but he was absolutely no different and
what he impressed upon me is that if i
was willing to
kind of stick with it and iterate and
learn and adapt he didn't give me any
other
tidbits there wasn't that much to give
so i think and and since then
part of the reason i teach and i've
thought for the last 17 years various
aspects of entrepreneurship innovation
is just that because i realized the more
people realize that this is not some
kind of you know kind of high brow
activity
the better the economy is so tell me
from that inspiration
to your first uh
startup in 1987 which was a couple of
years after this meeting
um after i had kind of exposed myself a
little bit to what innovation and
technology was
and without really an idea to start a
company around as i was getting close to
graduating i started thinking well
i should really keep that as a as an
alternative
in mind i went out and met a startup
company that was then just forming on
the west
coast realized that being employed in
one wasn't kind of
the same thing for me because i realized
other people were trying to figure out
what needed to be done and i was going
to execute it well that was interesting
that i didn't consider that to be the
same thing and
uh so i started i started kind of trying
to figure out okay if i was gonna do
this what would i do it with
um and pretty linearly i thought okay
what about making instruments for the
biotech industry like just like these
guys that made
instruments for the electronics industry
and
um started looking okay well what the
needs are so it's kind of a
pretty kind of classical way of thinking
about user
unmet needs first which again for for a
technologist wasn't
wasn't the first thing i thought they
come to them but the folks at slona
impressed upon me that
far more interesting than finding
customers for what i could do
was finding problems that were worth
solving and so
i looked at a bunch of different things
where we could apply
engineering mindset problem solving and
there were many because the field is so
new
and whenever i always find that if
you're working in a in a field that's
rapidly changing
there's an innate advantage that if
you're a newcomer
there isn't that much difference between
you you and the current players because
they also haven't been at it that long
so so that's how we that's how i started
so i basically
wrote a business plan as i was
graduating from mit um my first
meeting with a venture capitalist was i
think it was something like october 20th
30th or something like that 29th i
forget the exact date in 1987.
which happened i remember very well it
was a tuesday because it was the day
right after the stock market crashed
yeah so the monday that the
the black monday that that occurred
october 19th yeah 19. so it's it was the
day after
october 20th and and uh and i remember
having set up a meeting going to see at
the time famous venture capitalist
ginger moore
at oak ventures who in the life sciences
area is one of very few people
who invested and yeah i went to see her
and it was kind of quite a stark memory
because
you know i was 24 years old and i had
the business plan and
i didn't know what i was doing and here
was this person who had done this for 20
years
already and and she was completely
frazzled lost kind of devastated what
was going on and
i thought boy this is kind of it's a
weird introduction to the
to the field it was the best thing that
happened to me because frankly 31 years
later
you know we're even in the last few days
the feeling is quite similar
and so one thing i learned back then is
that if you have a calm day
it's actually not you know out of
character but it's usually just very
turbulent but anyway and
it also tested me because she her advice
to me was you know you look like you can
do this
you've got a good idea but you're never
going to raise money for the next year
go do something else because the market
has been devastated
and and it was interesting and so that
forced me to i didn't
take her advice but at the same time i
did realize it was going to take a while
to be able to raise money
and so i started trying to you know i
did i got a
side job at mit doing technology
licensing for a year
my professor was generous too kind of
they needed somebody to do some
licensing work
and i continued to develop the business
plan and and uh
got a lot of help from ed roberts who's
a kind of quite a legendary figure
in entrepreneurship uh and about
let's say maybe almost a year later i
ended up
getting some seed capital uh from quite
unlikely sources
uh meaning you know just random people i
had met a hundred different people
um i used to think and it's maybe useful
for your for your audience
at the time i used to think that if i'm
just successful ultimately
like i felt like a beggar i mean that's
kind of what it feels like i had
absolutely nothing
i had no technology i had a piece of
paper i had my back that's the idea
just the idea there was no proof of
concept there was no technology i was
licensing
nothing i just kind of i had an idea i
filed a patent
and it was closest thing to begging you
know you they have it you don't
you need it they may not need it as much
and
the chance that i'm going to give you
them anything back is pretty dubious
it's a similar act and i was telling
myself if you're successful
then you don't have to beg anymore yeah
and and 31 years later i realized that
if you're successful you beg for more
and more
but that that feeling doesn't go away
because anytime you're
you're trying to kind of
pre-sell the value promise of innovation
that isn't proven
and then eventually realize it and
reward people
it's a very it's an extreme form of
fundraising and and that's kind of
what's what comes with the territory so
um
i i ended up getting some seed capital
and started this company which which
ended up uh growing over some period of
time by
89 we raised some venture capital money
this was again the old days of where
venture capitalists used to
put a hundred thousand three hundred
thousand dollars in
uh and then at the most a million two
million in ever
so it was not like there was not seed
capital seed capital back then was 25
000
so so uh at the end this company called
perceptive buy systems ended up raising
11 million dollars from seven venture
capital firms
of which some venerable firms like
venrock
and bessemer and highland capital were
the big investors and
3i the bank of england i mean it was
crazy that they were all putting in half
a million million dollars
and ultimately the company actually took
off in 92 we went public in 97 we had
about 110 million in revenues we became
a very
uh um established player and leader in
the protein
protein analytical instrument field and
so that was that journey it was a
it was every every day was as
exhilarating as it was terrifying and
you know now this is a well-trodden
road but back then i remember very
clearly the most recent company that
inc inc 500 around the thing founded
founder of perillon had featured was
lotus
yeah and and of course lotus had
subsequently kind of
you know been sold and you know then
disbanded and it was
before that it was digital so it wasn't
like there were all that many companies
to
say i want to do that you had to figure
it out yourself yeah
that's incredible story so so you went
through this journey
you you know have an idea you incubate
the idea you persist
you form a team you raise capital you go
public then you're back for more
so so it's not what i've done for you
this has become
a lifetime this is your so tell us this
transformation so
what that was and what what caused you
to sort of think about this
sure well so first i'll go back to the
perceptive uh thing because
yeah one of the things you realize is
that you know
you know i ended up wanting i mean i did
this largely because i wanted to learn
how to do it
as opposed to the rewards of doing it or
or a lot of other things i just thought
it was
so unlikely that i could i could pick up
the minimum
needed to be able to succeed minimally
that
that that that was a real that was a
real adventure so you know i don't
i wasn't a good manager probably still
not a good manager
i didn't know how to raise money i did
not hire people i knew even less about
how to fire people
excruciatingly painful to do for the
first time you know i had hired a bunch
of
experienced people early on the one
thing i learned that i think is quite
uh kind of ageless in the in terms of a
lesson i use it to this day
is that you know when you're especially
when you're young and when you're not
expected to know much
the fact that you actually use that to
ingratiate yourself to people
so that they help you in helping you
figure out something
is a really powerful source of of of
kind of borrowed intellect i mean you
just cannot you cannot have wisdom
you know early on the best the next best
thing is to admit it yes
and to let other people give you their
wisdom and by this i don't mean
advisors and mentors i just mean people
who just kind of like you and decide
that they want to help you succeed
there's a lot of people out there
who as long as you give them it's like
permission marketing
this is like permission advice if you
give them the permission to give you
advice
and you and they see you use it not that
they go okay i'll take that into
consideration but you truly
kind of you know let go of pretending
that you know a lot
yeah and i didn't have that this problem
because i literally didn't know a lot
about anything i didn't
my phd had nothing to do with the
company did you know i knew the language
but not much i had no connections i was
an immigrant you know i
i came originally from lebanon escaped
the war
went to canada kind of grew up in a in a
foreign place so i had zero
expectations zero entitlement you know i
was not even american i was canadian
there was a lot of immigration issues
back then
you know of a different kind it was very
hard to get papers here there was no h1
visas were like a new thing and so
it's a it's interesting in hindsight
when you look at it but
um anyway so that you know so so
learning how to manage how to
how to create business strategy i never
to this day
i didn't i don't quite know what
strategy is
when it comes to a startup because you
have a hundred different things
you could do and a hundred different
ways of doing them and
choosing one i suppose a strategy yes uh
strategy is about choice that's what i
mean
it's about choice but in this case
there's like nothing else
it's a it's a it's a bit of an arbitrary
choice in the beginning
uninformed choice followed by lots of
iteration that's what i've learned
anyway so i so and but but before
getting to kind of what i do now
what ended up happening is in 94 or so
this company
you know i had iterated enough and made
enough mistakes that i had a
pretty good team the revenues were
growing we were expanding
and you know for the first time i
started realizing that okay
i kind of sort of get it and i became
interested in
innovation and value creation again and
i realized that in this company which
was by that time about 400 people
it's really hard to get rewarded for
innovation because even although we were
little
we were already too big you're already
focused for that you know there was we
had a
line of products and there's so much
more we could have done
so i started actually um experimenting
with
innovating with other people and helping
other people start companies so i was
still running this first company of ceo
of a public company
but but i was able to and when the board
my board knew it and were in support of
it
i was able to get involved in a few
other companies that
where people were you know either they
had a notion or an idea but by now i was
a little experienced
and so you know ironically you know they
were looking for my experience and here
i was still
winging it and so in the 90s kind of
between 94 and 97 i got involved in
about four other
roles as a co-founder of companies one
was a drug discovery company that i
ended up
being chairman enough and then we raised
capital from a number of other venture
capitalists to to grow
uh a very successful company it was sold
we started a cancer diagnostics company
started a cancer vaccine company
and i found this sounds like an
addiction like you were just starting
companies
it was interesting now i'll tell you
this was interesting it was not i was
not doing it alone so i had gone from
founder
to co-founder and co-founder is a more
scalable role than founder
but at the same time i but i was not an
investor in these things that i didn't
have i hadn't taken any money out of out
of my first company
um but but i'll tell you why i got
interested in this is that
i at the time the only kind of
entrepreneur there was was you know one
and done
or a serial entrepreneur and i had
thought
kind of skeptically around serial
entrepreneurship i no
i didn't know anything but i always
thought well why if you if you're
if you've if you've built a lot of value
you know what what is there to show
by doing it again and again and again a
silly thought but
i just so i thought what about parallel
entrepreneurship and back in the 90s i
used to go around telling people
you know entrepreneurship should be
parallel it's like like like parallel
chess you know where people play
simultaneously multiple people i always
thought that's incredibly hard
compared to playing one game it's hard
enough to play one and
and and i must say that actually uh
was just the kind of a hypothesis that
led to what i do now because
as i tried to do that i realized that
when you're doing something in parallel
that isn't as as defined as let's say
you know
calculus or something it's not a it's
not a discipline yet
um it forces you to focus on the essence
of what you're doing
and not all the idiosyncrasies of every
single case
so i started kind of forcibly to say
okay what can i do
if i'm spending a few hours a week on a
project that
in and of itself wants to change the
world but my role in it my involvement
it has to be
strategic surgical highly leveraged but
not
you know in infinite involvement of time
which is what you do when you're doing
one company yeah
and so those experiences kind of at the
end so in the end
the first company went public and it was
sold five years later
the three of the other companies went
public two of them were sold and this is
now in 97
98 and eventually i kind of started
getting more intrigued by parallel
entrepreneurship
and i thought i would devote myself to
not going the next step which is to say
why don't we instead if you can do this
in parallel why not do this
institutionally because the next step
there is is it a solo game
or is it a team game and that's kind of
what led to the thinking that led to
flagship
so tell us what flagship does yeah so
let's uh so flagship
um flagship is first and foremost a
life science innovation company um
we are we have our own way by which we
innovate which i'll tell you about
once we come up with something that's
worth
taking forward we form a company to take
that forward
and so we also had to figure out how to
do venture creation in a
systematic way we have our own capital
then we deploy into these companies
to help them grow for the first two
three years so
up until then they operate as fully
owned pieces of flagship
and then we spin them out and we spin
them out and for the first time
additional capital comes in but by that
time
the culture the senior leadership team
the early proof of concept the early
kind of customer or partner attraction
is there
and and it looks like a company ready to
eventually live its life on its own so
we're not interested in building kind of
subsidiaries
open-endedly every single thing we do
ends up becoming a company
or nothing but so we've become kind of a
creator of companies
around internal innovations now
sometimes these innovations drop from
external science and i can describe that
but but we're not only trying to find
science
and find what to do with it and create
companies that's become
vogue the last few years we've been
doing this for 18 years but we've ended
up in a place where
we think the sustainable way to do this
is to have your own innovation capacity
your own company creation capacity
initial growth
and then the companies have the
wherewithal to grow and
and and and compete and thrive that's
fascinating so
so walk us through one example of a
company that you guys have given
adversity from the start
to you know it's it's leaving the
flagship full um
there are many there's i think we've
we've been involved in doing about 50 of
these that are on based on internally
developed science and there's a whole
bunch more
that also include external but i'd say
one of the internally developed ones
that just recently went public i can
give us examples moderna
so moderna was an in and i'll tell you
kind of this we have this
fairly um let's say
prescribed process which the way people
think about entrepreneurship and
innovation especially breakthrough
innovation is that
it is unruly it is chaotic it is
inspired
it's none of those things none of those
absolutely none of those things i i have
a
completely contrarian view of that and
i've done it enough times in enough
different fields
then i think frankly just to be a little
controversial
i think that's an illusion in other
words i think that
because people haven't done that thing
before
it's exciting and you know unexpected to
them
but but actually pretty quickly it looks
like just another version of what
came before them because the historians
come and say well you know before there
was the ipad there was the ipod and
before that there was the
walkman etc and also when you look at it
that way you go well why were you
surprised
and that's when you realized that these
things are just evolving
and so i'll say i'll give you an example
in this company called moderna but
before that i'll tell you that
underlying how we think you can do this
systematically
is the notion that breakthroughs aren't
made by people
they emerge and the most understood
not well understood but understood
version of emergence that we know about
is evolution
which is that if you do variation
iteration
selection and iteration systematically
you will
the winners will emerge and when they do
they will look surprising but actually
they're the result of that process
they're not some inspired thought that
has nothing to do with that process
so hold that thought as i give examples
they'll all be examples of that
and that actually does cause you know
one to think differently about being
possessive
about all these companies and all these
innovations we're not
we don't we don't go around saying we
invented this we may file a patent and
get an invention
but where these ideas come from are very
emergent so in modernist case
talking about emergence we we understood
by following the various scientific
advances
that people were playing around with
converting fibroblast cells into
what's called induced pluripotent stem
cells these are
you know if somebody wanted nobel prize
recently for this these are called
yamanaka factors so it turns out that if
you take
differentiated cells and you introduce a
couple of three different proteins
four of them specifically these cells
can de-differentiate and look like what
came before them stem cells
they're not normal stem cells but
they're close to being
stem cells and so why do that because
then you can differentiate it make other
cells
so that was the general field and in
that field there had been some people
particularly at upenn
and and then more recently at children's
hospital here in boston who had been
playing around with using
what's called mrna messenger rna to use
these
to to to go into cells and express these
proteins
why had they done that because turns out
this mrna they could actually get a
better
transformation of these cells and so we
were aware of this work
and and we started asking kind of just
what if questions
so you your team is reading scientific
papers is this in the area yeah in this
case
yeah exactly and it's we do this all the
time so basically we're you're in the
mix of this flow of knowledge
it's not about reading papers for us as
much as just i mean we are we are
talking to lots of people about lots of
different things
and then or somebody says hey by the way
you know i just saw this data
yeah and then and then we actually read
papers in hindsight in other words we
read papers once we have an idea of what
to do
as opposed to read papers to get an idea
per se because just you know the signal
to noise and papers is gigantic you
can't
you know if you sit there and read a
thousand papers and that gives you three
ideas
hard to do anything else so it's a i'm
sure that can be done
too but we that's not the way we
approach it anyway so long story short
we
we started wondering for lots of reasons
that i can't almost reproduce because
you'd have to go back to 2010
in the summer and whatever else was
being thought of at the time
so understand by that time we had about
20 people that were doing this type of
activity
in various combinations for a living
yeah
and and so that's uh that's it's
important because these these ideas kind
of get
mixed and moved around this is not a one
person thinking deeply is not going to
get there so so we started asking you
know can you think about
we said why isn't there no drug that is
based on mrna
now if you go back 10 years drugs were
made out of proteins and small molecules
there had been an effort to use uh
viruses to introduce genes into the body
called gene therapy
and you know a person had been had died
early on and that whole field was shut
down
and there really was no other variation
to proteins and small molecules
and there'd been some efforts to try to
make you know not to get too detailed
but
other small dna rna molecules anti-sense
what's called and
and and we were aware of all this but
we're saying why why don't people
actually use this microrna molecule
and that's just a thought experiment and
you can go and ask answer that question
so you raise that problem you raise you
raise a what-if problem you don't say
you know initially we don't start with
we need to cure
melanoma we don't start a problem you
know what good is this mrna that can
transform cells because it's not good
for anything other than that
but we kind of abstracted and said is
there a combination of a solution
and a problem that we can identify
simultaneously
around this space and if there isn't one
then we move on and in this case that's
part of our methodology
in this case what we concluded was that
people had tried and failed
10 years earlier we understood why they
tried and failed we realized that there
was no obvious fix to it
but there was a direction of fixing that
you could modify chemically some of
these rna molecules
and they at least hinted that if you
kept doing that there may be better ways
we had no proof
there was no academic literature that
said this can be done
now we could have waited for that but we
probably would have been five six years
because
now there is academic papers from which
we could have started companies but
our our whole thing is to almost mine
this
you know science of the future to try to
solve problems of today
versus mind the science of today to
solve problems of the future
and that is exactly backwards and and
and and it's not any better it's just
that you look at the world differently
so
publications give you evidence for what
you want to do
but that's not why they published those
things they were thinking of a very
different thing
do you know what i'm saying so in that
regard that's that's a little bit so
in modernist case we identified
well the other thing that we do a very
integral part of what we do is that we
don't do this in a vacuum
so we go out and talk to people about
our
hypotheses these are not you're not
afraid of people taking your ideas no
and i'll tell you why so we we have this
no
so we use in order to try to create an
evolution so we're trying to create an
evolutionary
environment how do you do that uh the
scientific method
uses hypotheses and experimentation so
we actually do the same thing
we create value hypotheses we basically
say
i will take an mrna molecule formulate
it with this
agent stick it into muscle use muscle
none of it is true none of it's been
done before
but it's just a starting point we then
go with that
to a handful of folks that are both
experts and non-experts in the field
super important thing if you're going to
practice this kind of work is that
experts
actually are not the people who are
going to give you an idea of how to do
things dramatically differently because
they became experts by already doing
something dramatically differently
and now they're defending their
territory so if you go to talk to
somebody and say
can this be done out here most people we
talk to they can tell you
precisely why it can't be done which is
really valuable from a selection
pressure standpoint
but not the source of kind of and here's
a completely different way
so so other people though who don't have
expertise but have interesting
creativity so what we do is we take our
hypotheses and it's never one
because one of the things we've learned
is that if you start with one starting
point
you only locally search the space around
it
so we sample multiple different points
so it might be
how about mrna as a way to make more
proteins in a
you know fermenter how about so around
the theme we come up with totally
different value poles we try to identify
and then we we put a starting point then
we start talking and
what's what's been interesting and a
great learning exercise over the years
that we've seen
is that if you go to somebody with a
you know a bad idea but you actually
present it
in a precise way they will they will
tell you why it's a bad idea
and in that transaction something
happens
they feel smarter yes and you get
selection pressure
and so the way our process works is that
we actually do this
with multiple people so when you said um
you know aren't you afraid they're going
to take your idea
what are they thinking we just made it
up yes there's zero effect to it
literally zero factor just imagining
exactly it's we're just a hypothesis and
they know it
because then they tell us what proof do
you have is a nun yeah so then they
still engage because it's a almost
when we talk to these folks and this is
what we're known for we create a bit of
a
a an expert free zone in the sense that
you see look
these scientists you know here we are at
harvard and mit stuff
these people go to the the meetings of
their fields and they
cannot say something that does not seem
unbelievably smart
and reasonable actually make the point
let me
caveat reasonableness in my view is
like the gravitational force that keeps
innovation from happening
because people enforce reasonableness
in the scientific world on what you are
allowed to say
you go publish something in literature
that's not reasonable
to the reviewers yes you can get killed
i've done the whole study on that
right so ask yourself the question why
is it
that we think that the only innovations
worth working on start their life
reasonably
in fact i can show you many innovations
that are now
you know accepted as real transformative
things every one of them started life
unreasonably
and yet we go look for them in
reasonable
places by reasonable people who are
using reasonableness filters
to kill them so because we knew that
this was not the first thing i had done
we kind of say look let's just let's
forget reasonableness for a second just
think with us
and they tell us bad idea somebody in
japan had tried it experiment won't work
and we keep tweaking and tweaking and
tweaking this is different than kind of
like is you hear a lot in in silicon
valley speak kind of
in a pivoting this is not pivoting
evolution is the master pivot
it's like non-stop pivoting right
there's nothing to pivot from and two
you're just adapting and surviving so
that mindset is
super important now what happens is over
time things emerge
or they don't but they emerge where you
the next person you talk to goes
i don't they can't find fault with it
you know that because it frustrates them
and then they start telling you well do
you have any proof and you go no no i
just made this up it's just that we've
been iterate
and then that point is when we go into a
lab for the first time
and then and only then do we test the
idea now you can't test it fully
you can't test it where you know because
it takes years and years
but but we try to and one of the
expertise we we've developed over the
years
is how to to figure out what to test
first
and and this in you know in life science
you can't use these words
killer experiment because you know life
sciences can kill
but but you want to do the killer
experiment early
and so figuring out what's the killer
experiment or two or three or four
that if it if it doesn't fail allows you
to go forward
that's the trick and we do that in our
shop so in modernist case
we spent a couple million dollars about
six months
doing a set of key things but for which
we would not have proceeded so
we knew the idea had morphed and evolved
and it had some some resilience to it
we went into labs and asked specific
questions once we saw that actually some
of the things we were
hypothesizing could be done partially we
then decided okay
let's form the best economic value
creation engine known to mankind which
is a startup
in my view i'm biased and then we deploy
that startup to go after that value
pool in as many different ways as we can
so that's kind of
both moderna and the process so in 2010
summer
we did like what we call an exploration
uh what we
we tend to start these things we have
our own kind of terminology we don't
start companies
one of the things i had learned
throughout the 90s is that
companies are kind of almost immortal
you know once you start them it's hard
to kill them
so we thought instead of fighting that
just don't start a company
so we start these things we call proto
companies they're prototypes
and we don't name them we number them we
don't give people titles
and it's like a project except it's a
proto company it wants to be just like a
prototype product
it wants to be a product but you can
beat it up you can kill it you can loan
it whatever
that's how we work and we've we've
numbered them we're now yeah we've
probably done about a hundred of these
over time but
i think we're on number 65 because we
reset these every few every few years
and so moderna became i think what was
you know
24 what's the number it had or 18 i
forget which one it was
and then in 2011 we went into labs and
about six months later we started
realizing the data was
functional we we brought in at the time
a very early stage
uh at the early stage of company as ceo
usually we get a ceo much later
happened to be that i knew someone who
had kind of really interesting
experience not in doing this
because a lot of our ceos have not done
this before
so we experiment with people who have
kind of
more the personality and we can talk
about if you like
but uh in 2012 on the company's grown as
a standalone company and
and reached certain heights and now
today it has 21 clinical programs of
different drugs that it's trying to
develop about 12 that have gone into
humans
and uh it's about 700 person companies
yeah and you just had ipo as well
we just did an ipo yes it's been private
for for quite a while but
yeah and and this what i just described
to you is the case
similar case in a company called rubios
that that figured out how to take red
blood cells and make
therapeutics out of them which nobody
academically had proposed as a
therapeutic people were playing with red
blood cells people
again one of the things about is that
academic science for us is an incredibly
important substrate
that we recompose in order to do this
type of science
versus you know so i'll tell you the
stark contrast
again they both work but is that science
the way science is usually done is
money goes in to expand the boundaries
depending on how much money anyone's
place in the boundary gets how hard that
terrain is and how insistent the person
is
that defines how quickly that piece
expands and over time as this expands
some value opportunities come along and
then entrepreneurs
otherwise known as opportunists in the
better sense of the word positive sense
of the word that i use
find places where value can be created
and they start companies so there's this
adjacency oriented
value creation that that is that is
science
leading to innovation leading to
products and value
in our case we start with the kind of
pre or let's say foreseeing potential
value totally
if hypothetical finding the the
appropriate science
from which we could somehow link to that
product
and then figuring out whether you can
get there from here and that
allows us to try things that look as it
as an illusion completely surprising but
actually
follows another intensive process can
you give us an example of
so you described moderna as an
internally developed idea
you you've done a few that were
externally sourced can you can you get
walk us through a journey like that
where
where you saw something and then right
and so and so in that case i mean
there's several i can give you but a
very you know recent one that we've been
working on
is is a company that's today called
foghorn but started its life
as a academic project where
uh jerry crabtree and sagal kadosh
who are experts in the field of the kind
of the biochemistry of
chromatin remodeling and the protein
complex that it takes
to actually that that governs aspects of
regulating
expression of genes they had made some
some findings around that complex very
very precise
biochemistry and molecular biology that
had led to some interesting findings of
things that could be drugged and targets
early in the field a lot more work to do
but clearly we could associate with some
diseases by the time one of these things
gets to a place where there's already a
whole kind of infrastructure put around
it then you really just need capital
yeah i mean you need capital with
experience but you need capital
in this case what to do and
how to do it and what sequence to do it
and who to do it with all of that is an
open open-ended thing it's really more
suggestive science that's our the
closest we get to doing things
externally is that
and in this case we worked with them to
come up first without licensing the
technology or anything
we first worked on is this even worth
something so we did an exploration
that was inspired by that starting point
versus a completely hypothetical
starting point
still very poorly defined still followed
coming up with some value hypotheses
engaging different discussions iterating
around what's the version of this worth
creating
and then we formed a proto company
tested did some more experiments now in
this case there were experiments we
could
piggyback off of but they were as you
know fully half of
academic experiments cannot be
reproduced and do not
when they're taken out nothing wrong
with that but we have to test it
and so we did that and we could see that
this was a really fertile space
we attracted a team some of our team was
went in in the beginning and then we
attracted a team and now that company is
emerging
you know it's it's probably a year plus
away from having a clinical uh candidate
to go into
to test but it's becoming known as a
real
pioneer in that field of biology so in
this process you discussed evolutionary
process both for
foghorn and for moderna and the general
process
you're sort of out there doing this
hypothesis testing
how do you step away from confirmation
bias
right which is like you know like like
you know like like how do you
how do you stop yourselves from not
following a lot of ways a lot of ways a
very good point so
so first of all um scale we do
a hundred explorations a year so why
is that important because we did two
we'd have a lot of
a lot of bias but we are drowning in
things we could do
again and and if we open the aperture to
include external things it'd be a
thousand
so that's not the rate limiting step
what things to work on or not
second we've carefully designed
both the team we have and the way we
reward the players
such that they're constantly trying to
figure out how quickly they could kill
an idea so they can work on a better one
which is the exact opposite of what
happens in solo entrepreneurship
where if you kill the idea you're
unemployed and while you might have
another idea to work on you start from
scratch
so in this protocol phase we have many
more protocols than we could prosecute
so out of the 100
maybe 10 or 15 not the best 10 or 15 by
the way and absolutely arbitrary 10 or
15.
i mean it's best based on the fit
between the people
who are working on it and but it's not
like we don't
we don't have any kind of filtering
process we do these explorations
we have five distinct teams each about
10 people
all phds mds all who whom we've grown up
within
within our infrastructure that in teams
of two or three
duties expirations proposed protocol
companies then a handful of them get
taken into proto-company phase each one
gets a million to two million dollars
and then they do this they they run the
gauntlet of proving it
wrong one way you get no confirmation
bias is that everybody knows that if
they're working on
this they're not working on the next
moderna or the next rubios or next
so it's not perfect and of course
there's the third element
is that you know people like me and many
others now
who have done this for 15 20 years in
the flagship context we're 18 years old
now
are there to kind of keep reminding
people that
that they should question themselves i
mean one of the one of the things i
you know kind of deduced everybody who
does this long enough comes up with
their own
kind of words to say similar things in
my case
the mindset that i think saves you from
this kind of bias as much as possible
is that of a paranoid optimist and so
i've for a long time
tried to get across this notion that if
you're gonna do if you're gonna be in
this space
if you're a paranoid optimist by that i
mean you're not so optimistic
that you actually get reckless but
you're not so paranoid that you get
depressed
and this comes this this constantly
questioning
whether it really will work or how big
it will be or whether you should be
doing something else
that doubt you know doubtful optimism
which is really a tortured state to be
in
is perfect for evolution it makes you
poised it makes you constantly say what
can i do better can i do it differently
can i who else is doing it
and so that's that is a fourth way maybe
of protecting against the bias is that
you know we could not believe in what
we're saying
long enough because the doubt constantly
kicks in
and then we don't stay doubtful long
enough that we don't actually take some
risks so
it's really it's like it's like a gas
pedal and a brake pedal you don't want
to press them at the same time
but if you toggle between them and
you've got a steering wheel at least
simplistically
i think you can go places for the people
taking our course
you know they want to have access to
flagship they'll be around the world
they'll have access to some technology
and they'll have to sort of develop
these value hypotheses
um what advice would you give them so
they're they're
you know they're they're come across
something from our course or something
in their own
companies or in the labs near the
universities near them
and what advice would you give them in
terms of how to follow
your process on their own of course of
course no and in fact i think they can i
think very
some of what we do has to do with the
institution but
a lot of what we do is a mindset yes and
a methodology and that is not
and that is not dependent on the
institution so i'd say first and
foremost
you know again this everything i'm
saying has to do with science-based
companies uh because there's a lot of
other companies that are market-based
and
product iteration based and
execution-based that a lot of this stuff
is maybe overkill for you i don't think
there's any apps in our
in our so science-based company um
i'd say a few things one you've got to
ask yourself whether you really
believe that the solution should emerge
versus the solution should be asserted
and
that you just have to go look for an
application i believe that
i if you really start think rigorously
you know
you may have a technology for which you
try to find
a problem worth solving but then that
problem may be better solved with
something else
which you might also be able to go get
which might lead you to another problem
and those iteration loops might get you
a lot more of a valuable place
than just saying i'm a matchmaker this
technology
this application i'm done so first is if
you really want to dedicate the next
five ten years of your life which in
life science is a short time frame
in the tech world it's like two years
and you know it works doesn't work
you're out
so that's one thing i'd say think about
your own version of an emergent process
and and don't prematurely stop variation
stop selection
and by the way don't also just outsource
selection to investors
because if you're an entrepreneur and
you say you know i will come up with the
solution and then let's see what they'll
invest in
you'll be optimizing for investability
not
for what's worth building what's going
to make the biggest reward for you
or a society what's impactful it'll
purely be
custom made to the those days investors
and the more they invest and by the way
the reason people get frustrated is that
every investor is looking for a
different thing
and so they think it's noise and and
they can't get selection pressure out of
it
i think that's a good thing they should
themselves get
selection pressure from customers from
from you know people who are going to
actually prescribe the medicine or
patients or a combination of things so
that's
that's that's one set of things i think
the the second thing that that
this mindset gets gives you is
and we haven't talked about this so let
me just bring that out is that every one
of these kind of company
ideas you know big breakthroughs it
could be technology out of labs and by
the way i think there's a perfectly good
starting point
you want to think about it in its
ultimate embodiment
as possibly many many different
companies
right so so a seed that can give rise to
i mean think of almost a fertilized egg
that is a
an omnipotent cell when it comes to
differentiation it could make
liver cells it could make cardiac cells
it could make immune cells
it can go many different ways so if you
think about all those ways
right if you think about those ways then
you have to ask yourself
how long can i keep optionality even
while i'm building value because if you
just sit there and go oh my god i could
be anything you don't do anything
but the question becomes if i have
direction a
that locks me into becoming a skin cell
and that's it i'm done
or a cell that can still maintain
optionality
if you're in a brand new space you
really want to first up front think
about all the different versions
of a moderna that could be created and
and not
maybe you can't build the biggest
version on day one but
but choices you make that preserve the
biggest version keeps it alive
for the longest time probably the best
way to make decisions
very hard otherwise nobody you know
everybody who succeeds tells the story
as
though it was strategically thoughtful
the reality is you know i know and
everybody who tells the truth knows that
these companies
are the result of a whole lot of
accidental decisions
and some thoughtful decisions so i just
think you also want to be cynical
about thinking that thoughtfulness and
reasonableness and
advice is going to get you the answer
really you just want to keep optionality
so and the thing what you said was so
interesting to me was this notion that
you start with uh technology you find a
problem
but then you might find a related
problem and then you might find
something even bigger and you might find
a different technology
so it's this sort of this journey so
like these technologies that we give to
our students
are almost like starting points
absolutely it's a starting point for the
evolutionary process to kick in and
again it could be frustrating to be
honest with you because if you're
you know there's a lot of dead bodies in
evolution well that's true
that's true yeah that's absolutely and
so but i think if you say
i don't like the odds of evolution
therefore i'd rather you know
subject myself to a pure dead filter you
know dead filter is kind of
something you know filter basically is
you put a bunch of things and whatever
it gets forget through
evolution there is no filter it's a
selection process it's dynamic
but either way there's going to be a
selection of some sort
i would argue that in this version what
you if you survive
my guess is that you will be doing
something worth doing
in this other case if you survive you
might have just been able to raise money
or somebody buys you early on so i
i think i think it's okay but you gotta
almost prepare yourself for it and it's
not a
it's not and and to to to your point i
mean
problem discovery and solution
probleming are interesting iterative
loops i
the way i describe it to people is you
know think of think of yourself as an
insurgent
right we all know that in every field
there's incumbents
and these incumbents innovate in a
particular way they keep expanding what
their
dominant incumbent zone is ever so
gradually and you come in as an
insurgent
you don't have capital as your advantage
you don't have brand as your advantage
you don't have networks
but man you have one advantage and that
is it doesn't matter to you
what problem you solve with what
solution as long as you can create value
you make progress and that's the
advantage of an insurgent
what happens is oftentimes people lose
that advantage
and they force themselves to just do one
thing and and i just i think that that
insurgent
mindset is really really important
that's so cool
um so see a bit more about the selection
pressures that
people should put themselves under
around their ideas so
the mechanism you talked about is
talking to both experts and non-experts
people knowledgeable in the field but
not necessarily deep experts in those
fields
what else what else should they be doing
in this early stage where
there's some technology some notion of a
problem to be solved and then some
hypothesis
or hypotheses that they might have how
do they increase the selection pressure
yeah i mean this is the trickiest part i
should say that i when i say experts are
non-experts these can be in academia
these could be in startups these could
be in larger companies
there's a massive amount of networking
one has to do
so that they get they get to talk to
interesting people who will have a point
of view about what
they're doing it is a scary thing to
give
people your most cherished kind of
notion
which you think is the beginnings of the
next apple computer or the next google
when in fact it's just uh it's just an
idea you had you know whatever
so even if the technology has been
developed by the way companies that are
based on a certain technology
either you have patents that cover
technology or you don't
if you don't then you should go file
some patents
and if it's if it's truly an invention
and if you say well where do i get the
money to file the patents well that's
all
course on startup fundraising but let's
make let's assume you've got
the ability at least to have plans so if
there are patents then
you don't have to describe the patents
and enable people
you just have to say i've got this
patented technology that can do x
and if somebody says well how does it
work you can say look i'm happy to tell
you how it works
but let me first tell you what it does
and tell me whether what it does
is worth doing and if they say about how
does it work there's no
there's no logic that says unless i know
how it works i can't tell you
whether what you're proposing to do is
worth doing that's not true
so i think yeah and the other thing
we've learned over the years is how to
describe your
maybe invention or idea in ways that are
analogous to what you're doing not
exactly what you're doing
but that share the effect in common does
that make sense
i'm going to invent a digital camera and
i want to find out if
cameras underwater are useful well i can
take a non-digital camera
and i can say to you hey how about this
camera underwater and if they say well
how's it going to work
it's not digital and you say look let's
just assume i'm doing it you still don't
have to tell them you've got a digital
camera
you can give them an analog that has the
same
problem it's trying to go after get
feedback conversely
for problem people you want to give them
a sense of the solution you have
and see if how they so it's it's a
little tricky may sounds a little
complicated
frankly i think people do this anyway
they just do it out of desperation
because they just keep trying and trying
and trying and trying and all everything
i've said
ends up being tried it's not like we
came up with it because i derived it
from what i had been doing
it's just that i'm saying be thoughtful
about that being the act of
well i should mention to you in a more
kind of abstract way
years ago when i started teaching at
sloan this course in 2000
and they wanted me to teach a course in
entrepreneurship and i thought well you
can't teach entrepreneurship you know
this is a
you can maybe learn it but you can't
teach and i realized i had this problem
with the word entrepreneurship yeah
and i'll tell you to your audience
anyway because i don't want to miss the
chance
so first problem with the word
entrepreneurship is that any word that's
french
you know it's kind of a little bit you
know ostentatious or whatever so you
know
there's the old joke you know it's
living vaz in a vase about 500
so so entrepreneurs kind of this now
there's an ironic comment i'll make
about entrepreneurs since this the
audience
is is an entrepreneur uh by definition
is that it actually comes from the
french word
to undertake which is kind of ironic
because that means literally undertaker
uh which is kind of unfortunately where
we find ourselves often as entrepreneurs
is
you're kind of uh dealing with
undertaking uh in the other meaning of
the word
but the real the more serious part of
what i want to say is is this part which
is what i don't like is the ending of
the word
so ship as the ending of a word in
english
often means the the state of being
something
craftsmanship leadership friendship
sportsmanship
right all these ships mean the state of
being something
uh now i'm an engineer i don't do
engineership
you do engineering i do engineering
which is the act of doing something
and what i really find is an unfortunate
remnant of the history of this field is
that people
are thought to be something versus do
something
and therefore they spend all their time
trying to analyze the history the dna
the character of people who do this
whereas i think at some point you're
going to realize that a lot of different
kinds of people
can do this but this is entrepreneuring
it's not entrepreneurship
and as soon as society flips that which
is by the way happening
right around us all these incubators
mentor services all this
accelerates all of these are but but
when when i started 20 years ago
that was not at all invoked and we
thought i actually was crazy people who
were doing entrepreneurship
or the people that weren't so good at
school right exactly they were attention
deficit people couldn't get a job it was
kind of a funny
field and then when it succeeded people
celebrate it that's the other thing i'll
say is
you know it's great to celebrate things
but after a while you got to stop
celebrating this
because it shouldn't be this rare and it
shouldn't be this hard
the reason it is that people often tell
themselves this is like a lottery
it's not going to work and they do it
without a lot of forethought
and that's i think why courses like this
really should get people to say
i could do it by winging it but do i
want to actually have as my profession
improvisation i mean if you want to do
that you can be a comedian you can be a
jazz musician
but the notion that you're going to
improvise for a living and then take
unsuspecting people's money and then let
alone make something you put into
patience to save them
just think about the juxtaposition of
how we do entrepreneurship
and what we do with entrepreneurship
pretty big difference so
so i think i mean i'm very happy that
i'm living long enough to see
this this field literally become a
profession
and the reason i used to call it
parallel entrepreneurship is because
it was kind of so so ironic what does it
mean to do
you can be one thing how can we be
parallel entrepreneurs right
but once something becomes a profession
i think this is going to be
you know i think you know my kids who
are in their 20s now but the next
generation who does this
this will be more like a profession like
medicine
architecture versus this
sideshow that's celebrated and people
are getting movies made and they're
going to
get rich quick scheme it's going to be a
profession yeah two questions for you
well first one
one question for you is around we're
fortunate to be at mit
and harvard graduates from those schools
and so forth
and our networks are deep and it's easy
for us to
access people we just say oh you know an
alum from the school or so forth
others aren't from those schools how do
they build
networks how do they access networks
when they're
when they may not have the you know the
brand labels attached to them
well i mean of course brand labels are
one thing physical location is one thing
you know it's
it's look there's no i i don't have
a special insight to that i recognize
that that is
i mean not doing it isn't a possibility
here but figuring out how to do it you
know i think it's
it's at the end of the day relationships
lead to relationships and
and being connected wherever you are
being connected to
some lead thought leaders i mean first
of all i'd say that a
you know around the world people who are
the top in their field
are are both have other colleagues in
that field
but also are recognized for being top in
their field and never can open doors to
any other field
so i would look for you know somebody
who's top in a field even though that's
not what i'm working on
and see if i can develop a relationship
through whom i can get some
some credibility to be able to break
into this if you can actually go to a
place where there's people who have
expertise
it's really a question of just
persistence persistence
is there's no there's i don't know of
some magic
way of doing it there's people who are
great networkers yeah i'm not one of
them by the way so i
i whatever success i've had has been
despite that i
you know i had took me a long time to to
even say hello to david packard 30 some
years ago
it's just not but other people so the
other thing you got to do and it's just
a good good segue
is look you're not doing this alone and
so
part of the reason to have an early team
is that there'll be other personalities
and so if you're not that but there is
somebody who's that
their value is immense provided that
they're not sitting there saying oh
what's the product what's the science
and they may be out saying how do i
create relationships so that we can
actually get the idea exposed get
feedback
by the way and i said earlier the more
you make yourself
needy and accepting of their input the
more they'll be willing to do it's what
i've seen
yeah so don't go in there and make
pronouncements and
kind of say we've solved this problem i
mean i find
i've long thought that this whole
culture of you know 30-second elevator
pitches and
quick business plans and value
propositions and executive summaries
juxtaposed to something that's
completely unprecedented
i'm sorry it's laughable because you
know somebody i mean it's cute
but then somebody really just wants to
say what's the big idea
and why do you think you can work on
this and why you why this why now
those are the three questions and if you
just get people to say look i don't know
exactly i'm gonna do this so stay a
little vulnerable
yeah especially the early stage right
exactly exactly
and even later on look you're always the
earlier stage
of what you want to become so i actually
would advise not to become later stage
i think you want to stay early stage
moderna is an early stage company
moderna wants to have
you know 10 drugs in 10 different
therapeutic areas 10 years from now
so what is it compared to that nothing
early stage that
keeps you in that mode of constantly
think looking up
versus saying wow look how far i got i
must know something the worst thing you
could do
is to think you look down the mountain
say i must know how to climb because
look at where i am
bad idea let's just talk about
the your view about the sort of the
systematic nature of
innovation and how it can be
systematized what advice again would you
give
to our course participants around
how to flip their mind away from the
lottery perspective to the systematic
perspective like what how should they
reorient their own thinking around the
systematic nature yeah no i mean
look i think um it's
it's tricky right because because every
other
input and impetus we get about
entrepreneurship reinforces the lottery
mentality there's television shows
there's
there's this that and you know people
frankly i hate it because people also
describe their success story in that way
it's it's literally like saying you know
i conduct because i'm seven foot eight
well
what am i supposed to do with that right
it often isn't true
but in any case people describe it as
this fantasy
um by the way parenthetically i'll
mention one thing just because some
may resonate with some people you know
any any journey
in hindsight can be described
in a very different way than it was
actually prosecuted as a good example of
that is
is it's usually a chess game in the
beginning there's
a massive range of things you could do
at the very end there's only a few
things you could do
and if you look at the game backwards
the game looks entirely different
every decision you take now
informs your interpretation of how you
made that decision which is not how you
made a decision
that is why a lot of people tell
entrepreneurship or for that matter
innovation journeys
not accurately at all because that they
don't describe it the way they were
thinking about it
so that's just a so your question about
how do they think more systematically
about it
again i i would say you know keep an
adaptive evolutionary mindset
try this kind of variation selection you
might ask how long do you
iterate because if you keep iterating
forever you're never going to do
anything
so there's this kind of difference
between what's possible and what's
real and kind of you got to extract some
reality out of it
but i you know i think i think it isn't
you know i don't have kind of
rules of thumb i'd say don't get trapped
into thinking that all you need to do is
to find
a base use case for something that
exists you can do that by the way
if if you go through all of this and you
find that the first thing you thought of
is the most valuable thing great you'll
be well served because if it turns out
not to be
you have other things to do this was not
a waste of time
but if you think your job is to find
that one thing
as though there is one thing that's
where you get into the lottery trap
you know i long ago this will kind of
maybe revolt people to hear me say it
but i hope they take it with a
bit of a grain of salt long ago somebody
when i first came to mit used to use the
expression that the lottery is a tax on
the mathematically impaired
yes and if you just stop and think about
it in reality
there's no version of a lottery that
makes any and yet we do it because we're
human beings
and we're optimists and we think that we
can beat the odds
there's an element of a lottery that's
always going to be there with startups
an element what i call a leap of faith
right there's a leap of faith which says
i can reason my way to this point
i want to do something that's a little
further or a lot further i have to leap
that we're never going to take away i'm
not advocating that because it's
contrary to my reasonableness discussion
before
however when you say well it's a lottery
anyway
so why not buy 10 tickets why not buy
you know get all my earnings and put it
into the lottery
that level of kind of you know trying to
rationalize that there's some
you know that's dangerous yeah and i
think this field
a lot of failures you've probably
studied this a lot better than i have
but
a lot of players and startups i think
are avoidable
and some are not now we report on the
data on both
and i think over time the the first
category should diminish
the other has to do with uncertainty and
competition and all sorts of things
we're not going to get away from
you